- [Instructor] We're told that Ben's home
is x kilometers from an ice cream shop.
Jerry's home is y kilometers
from the same shop.
Then it tells us they each left
their home at the same time
and met at the ice cream
shop at the same time.
Ben walked an average speed,
let me do this in a new color,
average speed of five kilometers per hour.
And Jerry rode his bicycle
at an average speed
of v kilometers per hour.
Write an equation that
relates x, y, and v.
Pause this video and
see if you can do that.
All right, so let's just remind ourselves
how distance, speed, and time are related.
You might be familiar with things like
distance is equal to rate times time,
or another way you could think about it is
you could write the distance
is equal to speed times time.
Or if you wanna solve for time,
you can divide both sides by speed.
So you could get distance over speed,
over speed, is equal to time.
Now the reason why I set it up this way
is that we know that Ben's time
and Jerry's time is the same.
They covered maybe different distances
at maybe different
speeds, but it took them
the exact same amount of time.
So Ben's distance divided by Ben's speed
should be the same as Jerry's distance
divided by Jerry's speed.
So let me write that down.
So Ben's distance, Ben's distance,
divided by Ben's speed,
and let me write it in this color,
Ben's speed should be equal to
Jerry's distance, Jerry's distance,
divided by Jerry's speed,
Jerry's speed.
Now which of these do we know
or do we already have variables to find?
Well we know that Ben's
distance from the ice cream shop
is x, so this is represented by x.
We know that Jerry's distance
from the ice cream shop
is represented by y, so this is y.
we know that Ben's speed is
five kilometers per hour.
So we're assuming everything
is in kilometers per hour.
So this would be five.
And then Jerry's speed
is v kilometers per hour.
So this is v right over there.
And so we could rewrite all of this as
x over five
is equal to y over v.
And once again, the
way that I set this up,
the left side is the
amount of time Ben takes
to get to the ice cream shop.
This is, on the right hand side,
this is the amount of time Jerry takes
to get to the ice cream shop.
And they tell us it's
the same amount of time.
So there you have it.
We have an equation that
relates x, y, and v.
And they gave us the five.
Now it's completely possible
that instead of the five,
they gave us something else
and Ben's speed was the variable.
If they did that, then we
would have a different given
and maybe a different variable,
but the structure of our
equation would be the same,
that Ben's distance divided by Ben speed's
would need to be equal to Jerry's distance
divided by Jerry's speed.